in a vegetable kinda DVD version
yourself of the Sorokin that's it you
pronounce guilty of espionage and
sentenced to 16 years hard labor a
former US Marine and British Canadian
and Irish passport holder Paul Whelan
has always maintained his innocence he
was arrested 18 months ago at this
upscale Moscow hotel in what he claims
was a political sting operation the man
he thought of as a longtime friend in
reality his lawyers say an agent for
Russia's federal security services out
for a promotion who planted a flash
drive in his pocket this has been a
closed trial on the grounds that it
contains state secrets which means that
none of the supposedly damning evidence
confirming Paul Weiland guilt has been
made publicly available in a statement
the US Secretary of State said he was
outraged by the verdict and demanded
weland's immediate release the US has
taken the lead on this case from our
side Wieland's brother David told us it
was time for the British government to
do more I would like to see them speak
out for their Simpson their silence is
as damned a problem for us as their
perhaps to do nothing for Paul in March
Russia repeated its request for the
release of Russian nationals from u.s.
jails given the Cova doubt break I'm in
no position to discuss new prisoners
exchanges we've just the following has
now just become a convict in the Russian
system I'm advocating for justice from
Wheelan said in court this was not
justice but slimy grubby greasy Russian
politics he says he will appeal the
verdict dynamic new Sky News Moscow